jacques attali bonsoir
vous connaissez mathilda may voilà bien
de jouer dans le dernier film de chabrol
c'est ça qui sort quand le cri du hibou
28 octobre le 28 octobre
science d'al qassam qui va vous
interviewez avec moi laurent voulzy que
je ne vous présenterai pas richard
bohringer non plus et philippe guérin
qui travaille son bain de minuit avec
moi après ma question que je vais vous
poser c c'est quoi la vie d'un
d'un conseiller spécial du président de
la république ça consiste en quoi c'est
heureusement fred inattendu et
d'improvisation s'essaya rien de
régulier quelque chose continue c'est le
rythme du conseil des ministres mercredi
auquel j'assiste le fait d'être tout le
temps alors ce qu'il peut se passer des
événements d'accompagner le président en
voyage à l'étranger de voyager beaucoup
pour lui soit de façon ouverte soit de
façon plus discrète
et puis de voir beaucoup de gens de
réfléchir de proposer des idées de mire
avancer les choses est ce que le
président doit toujours savoir où vous
êtes par exemple quand vous partez en
week end quelque part vous dit où vous
êtes comme les médecins il ya un grand
médecin qui doit toujours savoir où
trouver comme maintenant en ce moment et
vous trouvez quand le temps d'écrire
alors j'écris par définition très tôt le
matin à bombay entre 4h et 7h du matin
vous sortez pas le soir j'ai pas besoin
de beaucoup de sommeil je peux sans
retouche je peux me lever très très fier
robin jusqu'à 11 heures du soir barbara
se gagnent beaucoup être conseiller
spécial du président public
bah spécialement payer vous pouvez nous
dire combien je suis membre du conseil
d'état oui ça fait combien cela en tant
que membre du conseil d'état je garde
mes fantasmes c'est pas terrible
et voilà ça s'arrête là c'est tout et de
quel personnage célèbre par exemple dans
l'histoire de france vous auriez aimé
être le conseiller spécial en dehors de
françois mitterrand par exemple
clemenceau robespierre léon blum
difficile à dire c'est une chose de
hasard jeu plus donc je pourrai plus
fixer des ambitions par rapport à
l'écriture tel ou tel grand écrivain que
par rapport à la politique la politique
est pour moi un hasard de vie je trouve
que j'ai la chance d'être
croisement ou un homme politique
important a eu besoin ou envie ou
d'avoir un intellectuel au près depuis
mai
ce n'est pas une finalité pour moi
d'après le président mitterrand est ce
que vous pensez vous envisagez pouvoir
être conseiller spécial d'un autre
président non pas le pas le moins du
monde
encore une fois qu aux etats unis c'est
assez banal cantons universitaires non
vous devez une banale de dire une
intellectuelle ma pour un temps et
c'était annoncé ses idées dans la
politique et puis ensuite il retourne je
sais le faire
d'autres formes de communication c'est
mon cas il se trouve qu'en europe c'est
très peu fréquents on arrive j'en ai je
crois que tissus et des arts dans un
pays européen à l'avoir fait il faut
s'habituer à cette idée que les
intellectuels peuvent venir jouer leur
rôle dans la politique tout en restant
le même il y en étant pas forcément
condamnés à basculer dans le champ de
l'action politique pour prendre des
est-ce que vous avez une fois l'algérie
est un pays fantôme avec qui n'existe
plus le jury vous aviez connu mais ce
qui vous arrive d'y retourner d'y penser
dans rêvé la nuit c'est chic jerry très
jeune donc
moi je suis juif et
adrien double fantôme double inexistence
dans la racine c'est peut-être ce qui
m'a poussé comme d'autres a joué
beaucoup dans le concept c'est à dire à
vivre sans racine c'est à dire avoir des
racines dans la tête
est ce que vous êtes croyants oui
le soir du kippour vous êtes resté chez
vous vie privée vie privée mais vous
pratiquez yvelines vont me répondre et
fabien ont montré un petit sujet qu'on a
fait avec philippe b raf
on a pris un imitateur qui a pris la
voie du président mitterrand et qui a
appelé les présentateurs du journal
télévisé en leur demandant à la veille
des élections à six mois des élections
de parler un petit peu plus de lui de
mieux le traité dans les journaux
télévisés et vous allez voir certains
ont tout de suite découvert la
supercherie
peut-être parce que c'était ma limite et
peut-être parce qu'il pense pas que le
président mitterrand soit capable de ça
mais il y en a un et non des noirs
il s'est laissé franchement attrapé
alors on va voir le sujet si vous voulez
bien je peux vous d'abord comment te les
bus me suis mis trop comment j'en avais
corps et tri oui et je voulais tout
d'abord vous féliciter personnellement
je suis monsieur mitterrand côté make up
léger vent n'ont pas de temps à perdre
je tenais à vous féliciter pour votre
journal c'est que je suis sensible au
fait que les journalistes eu de l'es5
une certaine intégrité dans la période
de troubles et bien une fugue du visuel
je suis françois mitterrand
et je vécu seul président mais
malheureusement j'ai un rendez vous bon
vous allez vous qui s à 9 de
plaisanterie parce que vous venez saison
non mieux vous avez vous ce soir
comment gérez vous ce soit leur métier
je suis françois mitterrand mais
normalement être moins dans les
présentes rives que vient d'appeler un
bureau j'ai un rendez vous dans cinq
minutes
alors il faut absolument que j'y aille
alors maintenant on va les masques
ça tombe bien belle et metz j'ai voulu
quand même mais vous c'est que nous
approchons de l'échéance électorale
importante
je voulais savoir s'il était possible et
d'être invité prochainement dans votre
journal c'est tout tout est possible je
serai fort plate et d'accueillir le
président de la république sans problème
mais il faut que nous trouvions une
opportunité je n'aime pas tellement ses
interventions officielles telles que
nous avons eu comme eux par exemple
leurs enfants bus savez je vous
expliquais monsieur le président je suis
un peu étonné de coups de fil et j'ai
l'impression actuellement 2
que l'on voit qu'une blague alors
j'aimerais que vous me rassure y est est
ce qu'il m'est possible de repasser un
coup de fil s'il vous plaît à vos
services de façon vous avoir au
téléphone coûts de gestion
mais ce n'est pas une plaisanterie alors
je vous promet beaucoup plus vraiment de
ré à ce moment là ce que je vous propose
c'est tout simplement du rap l'elysée
aucun d'eux 92 81 00 parce que je vais
recevoir le président du conseil italien
lors la place rapidement je voulais vous
remercier personnellement pour eux et
les missions de deux christine ockrent
de grande qualité nous entretenir une
autre émission
j'aimerais passer dans une émission
autre que le journal ou et spéciales
soit un dégagement se tromper que madame
ockrent vous en mettez le parler alors
vous en était le bar les ados oui je
m'entendais allô allô monsieur mougeotte
ce que je postule ya un problème moi je
vous demandais comment expliques-tu
sommités on parle au téléphone parce que
on s'est trouvé devant un imitateur
il a fallu lui dire essayer de ne pas
faire de limitation de seine d'essayer
de faire de limitation de conversations
intimes sais pas je ne suis pas
imitateur dont je ne saurais vous
répondre je n'ai pas trouvé que ce soit
très précis dans le vocabulaire mais
comment est-ce que par exemple quand il
vous appelle il dit à lauzach allô
monsieur attali quand même les détails
matériels font que ce ça ne se passe pas
comme ça vous savez que c'est lui qui
appelle mais est ce qui lui arrive des
fois de composer lui-même le téléphone
numéro avec la personne au bout du fil
disent non n'êtes pas françois
mitterrand oui bien sûr que ça arrive
une anecdote qui est arrivé et non pas
lui mais un de ses prédécesseurs
chaque président a abdiqué sur son
bureau plusieurs téléphones sont pas sur
les détails de thèmes et un téléphone
qui est une simple ligne de
communication de ptt et il
le président pompidou art si un jour une
communication comme ça quelqu'un qui
téléphone et qui insistaient beaucoup
pour parler à la personne qu'elle
croyait avoir bout du fil et les
malfrats qui vous est il arrivé il a
répondu en tout cas at il raconté à
madame si vous saviez c'est vrai que ça
arrive parfois il arrive que le brillant
hassanine il peut téléphoner il
téléphone très souvent lui même il peut
très bien avoir téléphoné à 2
on a 10 km et ça vous ça vous
vous étonne que ce soit le présentateur
du journal télévisé du service public
qui sont atteints soif pas vous y voyez
quelque chose de structurel ou au
contraire est-ce que ça vous saviez mois
habituels et souvent ce que je viens de
sa wii c'est oui c'est parce qu'ils
débutent et qui n'a pas encore reçu de
coups de téléphone de m les autres
connaissent sa voix fait richard hill à
dire très humain ces précisions de la
bulle du téléphone lui-même sympathie ou
simple atterri sur le pâtis non mais
c'est pas lui c'est ce que tu penses que
le président de la république peut
appeler des gens comme ça pour leur
demander de parler un peu plus de lui à
la télévision est ce que ça te sens tu
du niveau des supers sur eux dans le jeu
parce que c'est pas possible c'est pape
est si lent je pense pas je pense pas
qu'ils aient des gens pour ça que je
crois que c'est jacky appelle même pas
sûr
enfin je sais pas mais pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu